[Musique]
comment les côtés aussi car président
met en scène leur double qu'idc 210
contre marine le pen la dérive de
monsieur mariani est évidente et donc
nous nous sommes séparés sur le plan
politique
sur le plan géopolitique sur le plan de
la proximité tout simplement
donc maintenant on fait un adversaire
j'ai essayé de ne pas trop me
reconnaître mais il y avait des éléments
cette espèce de placidité de normalité
exigeante
même si je dois le dire je ne m'énerve
jamais il est entouré de gens qui ne
sont pas fréquentables
parce que aujourd'hui présent ils
n'habitent pas cette région il travaille
pas ici vient contre son gré en fait
donc autrement gré mais oui je serai du
mazout masochiste de faire une campagne
électorale contre oman grayan j'ai une
grande admiration pour jean dujardin
j'aime cet acteur alors après de là à y
voir une fois encore que je passe une
étape c'est douloureux pour moi nicolas
dupont aignan député debout la france de
l'essonne annonce soutient soutenir la
liste de valérie pécresse pour la région
ile de france dit non mais qu'ils soient
rassurés la s'est passé c'est pas
totalement lui s'est pas totalement moi
c'est nous c'est ça fait pas mal ça
c'est moi qu'on puisse dire merci
monsieur dupont aignan il le voilà il
maintenant il souhaite se rapprocher des
républicains bon c'est son nous c'est
son choix
me reprocher d'avoir quitté ma région et
ses camps comme vous on a demandé la
nationalité mauricienne
il ya une dizaine d'années je trouve ça
je les placer mais je l'aimé ou pas du
tout moi je paye mes impôts ici ce qui a
fait que alors pourquoi parce que je
travaille j'ai un métier
monsieur mariani contrairement à l'or
merad métier vous êtes un alimentaire la
vie politique
vous êtes sur les ordres de madame le
pen sale ambiance entre les ministres ça
préfigure quoi pour vous la comédie
puisque dupont monsieur dupont moretti a
lui même indiqué qu'il voterait xavier
bertrand dont xavier bertrand il est le
candidat des manuels macron voilà faut
l'assumer la manière que monsieur
musulin
en paca il est aussi le candidat d'
emmanuel macron vous ressemblez plus
apte en plus à christian estrosi
franchement non mais parce qu'il est
capable d'affirmer n'importe quoi avec
un aplomb extraordinaire
soyons certains bourgi lui permettrait
des flammes ont installé sous les yeux
merde et président de cette métropole et
qui est un homme très bien monsieur
soudas oui je sais je soutiens et
heureusement qui me soutient là je suis
très fier d'ailleurs c'est lui aussi qui
vous a entraîné à vous rapprocher de
macron je suis pas né avec une cuillère
en argent dans la bouche j'ai grandi
dans une cité j'ai pas fait d'études
moi je fais pas partie de ce petit
microcosme médiatico politique qui passe
son temps à se regarder le nombril et je
dis pas ça pour vous mais c'est ça de
façon générale l'analyse de l'analyse du
propos rapportés franchement ça
m'intéresse à la comédie m'intéresse
c'est qu'il ya des femmes qui sont en ce
moment battu par leur pouvoir tester en
france détesté en catalogne on sans
moralité je lisais même en catalogne qui
avait exigé de se faire payer vingt
mille euros par mois pour faire une
tournée municipal détestable c'est un
homme qui a perdu tout sens de la
réalité et qui vient monsieur carnaval
faire son tour en nous insultant
avec les mots de la droite et l'extrême
droite le fameux variant delta arrive
qui se diffusent beaucoup plus
rapidement que les précédents variant et
on le voit qui touche les personnes qui
ne sont pas vaccinés ou qui n'ont eu
qu'une seule dose est ce qui nous
implique ce qui nous impose d'être
encore plus rapide dans cette campagne
de vaccination imaginez un gigantesque
cube de glace 2 7 km de hauteur cela
représente 300 milliards de tonnes de
glace
et bien voici le volume que les glaciers
du monde entier perdent chaque année à
gauche du réchauffement climatique
notre ennemi c'est le virus c'est par le
vaccin
entre le axe 1 centralier seul entre
amis et la fente ce siècle
la hausse pourrait attendre 1 m 10
suffisant pour noyer les côtes
les villes les ports et provoqué l'exode
de centaines de millions de personnes
vous serrez la main je pense vous serrez
la main encore tous les deux non non non